you may notice a new way to pay online
this holiday season but it could cost
you several tech companies including
after pay Clara and a firm are offering
point-of-sale loans or instant
installment plans as an alternative to
credit cards you can apply online or on
an app personal loan balance is in
America which include this type of
financing more than doubled since 2014
they grew 5 times faster than credit
card debt between the first quarter of
2017 and the same period this year
consumer watchdogs are worried about who
the loans are targeting tonita copal is
here to explain it all to us Tony good
morning good morning loans like this are
approved in seconds and you get the
money immediately for the item you're
buying which sounds pretty good and
lenders say it's a responsible option
but with interest rates as high as 30%
critics the old fashioned loan sharking
with a Silicon Valley smile whether you
need a new watch a new sweater or the
perfect decor for your holiday party
what you no longer need is money not
even a credit card to make it yours
what changed by now pay later is the
premise of the San francisco-based a
firm founded by Max Levchin in 2012 how
many people are doing this we've never
really disclosed but it's millions of
millions how was that and billions and
billions of dollars in loans outstanding
correct demand is driven in large part
by Millennials or Generation Z
many fearful of credit card debt a firm
says because their payment plans have a
predetermined interest rate with no
compound interest or hidden fees
customers know exactly how much they'll
pay each month for the product they
purchase so we limit the transaction to
a thing that you want to buy at a store
that you want to buy at a price you want
to buy and it creates financial
certainty for our customers especially
the ones that really need what's the
average size of an affirm loan $799 and
how long does it take to paid off the
typical term
about eleven months left chin says the
company uses its own formula to approve
loans to a wider pool of people
including people with bad credit scores
or no credit at all each purchase will
show up as a separate loan on your
credit report and issues with a loan can
quickly hurt your credit score
hey everybody biggest barbecue here
checking in from Conroe Texas Stephen
and Jessica Brisbane learned that last
year when they tried to return a camera
they purchased with a firm to promote
their business yet smellivision we
didn't open the box we slap that return
sticker on sent it back expect that
everything at us moved from there while
they say using the service was easy the
process to finally cancel there it was a
nightmare I mean absolutely absolutely
nightmare this just has the features
that we need seven months later you know
two things on my credit and having a
hard time getting a loan you know it
just wasn't right the way it's
structured it is not let's sit down and
think moment it's do you want to make
the purchase or not
Lauren Lineback is executive director of
the consumer advocacy group community
financial resources she warns that a
firm's average interest rate is 17%
similar to most credit cards and that
the marketing seems to encourage
irresponsible buying by young people who
may not be able to afford it so the
product could be a very helpful product
but right now the way it's being
marketed it's enabling bad behavior what
do you say to the criticism that you are
enabling frivolous classic consumer
purchases that people don't really need
I just find it very very difficult to
claim the authority that we know what
people need you're inviting people down
a road that they may not be able to pay
the bills on no I am inviting them down
the road to responsibly have access to
think that they should be able to afford
but it's a treadmill so oh god I used a
firm to get a pair of pants for work in
the fall I paid it off it cost me $20 in
interest that's $20 I don't have for
that pair of pants in the spring but now
I'm on another
it's $40 and it's $80 the alternative to
go pamphlet to chez Max Levchin we asked
a firm what happens to customers loans
if products like the brisbin's camera
are returned and the company says that
return policies vary but if the merchant
offers a full refund the company will
work to on wine the loan now here is the
bottom line and this is from consumer
watchdogs and I realize it's easier to
say this and actually follow it but if
you can pay your credit card off on time
it's likely going to be at a lower
interest rate than a firm and better for
you and if you can't well here's the bad
news you may not be able to afford the
item might be wise not to buy it or just
have a debit card and not with a large
you know come to one of the concerns its
companies like affirm approve 80% of the
loans versus store credit which is like
50% of the loan and don't do what I used
to do which is try to live off of bread
and pasta for months in order to pay off
your bills max is interesting that I'll
buy the pants if it's going to cost the
shirt off your back max yes were you
escorted out of the building prior to
that interview founder yeah I really
don't think that we need more financial
education in this pursuit about credit
card debt about all of that because I
think you're young yeah you look right
you know learning the hard way and it
takes a long time to dig yourself out
yep
well I learned the hard way too you know
we're max my credit card when I was in
college and had to get one those
consolidation loans and I swear I would
never do that again